this is where our acting abilities are
truly tested
while the maze runner may be a dark and
gritty trilogy
the onset antics were anything but
working long hours on set across
multiple movies builds strong bonds
[Applause]
it's easy to tell the cast of maze
runner loves spending time together from
the hilarious outtakes
and behind the scenes footage of them
goofing up or killing time on set
bloopers gag reel the desert landscapes
in the scorch trials look amazing
because they were filmed on location
but filming in the deserts of
albuquerque new mexico was no easy feat
ki hong li who plays minnow describes
the challenges they faced
trying to climb sand dunes and fighting
strong winds to keep their eyes open
and keep their balance i mean it's hard
to you know sprint up a
crazy incline of a sand dude and then
get up there and look cool
dylan o'brien and thomas freddy sangster
who play thomas and newt
seem to have a running joke that began
during the filming of the first maze
runner movie
they plan to surprise the rest of the
crew by kissing in the middle of filming
a scene
dylan backed out at the last second but
it wasn't the last time the two would
pull that particular prank
they know all about newt miss or the
part of the maze runner fandom that
ships thomas and newt
romantically and they seem pretty cool
with it
[Music]
really it's a really sweet relationship
i think they have dylan and thomas were
hardly the only pranksters on set
during the first maze runner movie will
poulter galley
secretly wrote fake love letters to
dexter darden frypan
signing them anonymously wow
he would stick them in dexter's pockets
on set while he wasn't looking
it had him totally baffled according to
blake cooper
every time dexter would take off his top
suit he would find these letters
he was so confused and had no idea who
was sending them to him
he was an old friend in the scorch
trials
the glader's escape from the facility is
nearly foiled by a door that refuses
them access
while they desperately try to get it
open the tension is high
as thomas and the others hold off jansen
and his security detail
until freedom is finally within their
grasp however
dylan key and the others could not keep
it together despite filming such a tense
scene
laughing and cracking jokes as they
fumbled with the keycard
this scene from the death cure where
thomas newton galley captured teresa and
sneak into wicked headquarters would
have gone a lot differently if thomas
had as much trouble with the wicked
securities gear as dylan o'brien did
with his props and costume
the masks worn by wicked security force
seemed to restrict the wearer's field of
vision
leading to some clumsy moments that
landed in the movie's gag reel
nothing is quite as distracting as food
when you're in the middle of a busy
filming schedule
what does everyone want from mcdonald's
in the middle of this scene in the death
cure where jorge is giving some vital
exposition about the last city
if that city is still standing that's
the last place you want to go here mom
the take is interrupted when someone
walks into the take with a tray of food
giancarlo esposito breaks character and
the whole scene
immediately derails maybe it was takeout
from los poyos hermanos
and that's why he was so tempted i want
a piece please bring over here
to stay pumped for all those
high-intensity action sequences or just
to have some fun between takes
dylan o'brien loved dancing on set
sometimes he got other cast members to
join in on the fun
and even the person behind the camera
this clip of the gladers doing a
choreographed dance together is a fan
favorite
with lots of edited clips setting the
dance to various different songs
hey baby thomas brody sangster
and dylan o'brien like to have fun with
takes they know aren't making the final
cut
you boys coming or what
in an interview dylan said being on set
was like a sketch show and he's always
trying to get thomas to crack
up thomas wasn't the only cast member to
fall victim to o'brien's comedic improv
either
it speaks to his skill as an actor that
even when cracking a joke he stays in
character
long after everyone else is burst into
laughter what's with the rap man
i don't know what i think he's on gaming
after arriving in london for part of the
death cure press tour
thomas ditched dylan at the airport
since thomas is from england going
through customs didn't take as long as
it did for his american co-star
thomas unceremoniously left dylan behind
sending him a text that he was already
in a car on the way to his hotel while
poor dylan was still being processed in
customs hey man uh
sorry i already got through into the car
um i'll see you tomorrow
guess we're not hanging out today
filming on location in baton rouge
louisiana for scenes in the glades was
no picnic
in fact it was full of snakes in fact a
snake wrangler was brought on board to
keep the actors and the animals safe
jacob lattimore who plays jeff had a
close encounter with one when he nearly
dropped his hat on the ground while
filming
and spotted a snake on the ground nearby
had he actually dropped it
jacob told j14 i would have said goodbye
to the hat because there was no way i
was going after that
how long do you think we can last snakes
weren't the only wildlife that disrupted
the sets of the maze runner trilogy
bugs got in the way of filming too blake
cooper and caia scodelario had some
insect encounters that ended up in the
gag rails for maze runner and the scorch
trials
flake and dylan bond over the fate of a
moth that flew directly into the flames
of a torch while kaya's entrance into a
dramatic scene was thrown off by a bug
flying directly into her face a moth
just flew in there and just burned it
okay in the death cure while
infiltrating wicked headquarters to
rescue minnow
the gladers set up freeing a group of
immune children along the way
dylan o'brien and kya scotillario had
trouble staying serious during this
tense exchange with kaia playfully
pouting to get a laugh out of dylan
and dylan cracking jokes about finding
minnow and leaving the immune kids
behind
all right everyone back in your cells
this was a mistake we're very sorry we
were looking for one person
you're not saved kihong is just as much
of a jokester as dylan
goofing up several takes of a scene
where teresa tries to convince mino that
her actions are for the greater good
kaya is just as bad unable to stop
herself from breaking into giggles when
she's being held down and attacked
he really shows off his excellent
comedic timing in these bloopers
don't tease me bro
nothing ruins a dramatic reveal like a
misbehaving set piece
sometimes these inanimate objects have
comedic timing that's so perfect it's
almost as if they have a mind of their
own
like in this blooper from the death cure
newt isn't to let thomas sneak off to
fight wicked all alone
punctuating the moment by confidently
opening the door to reveal that frypan
is also offering his support
well we started this together too bad
the car didn't get the memo that this
scene was supposed to make them look
cool
sometimes props can mess up a perfectly
good take kaya seems to struggle with
medical equipment
in particular in these bloopers from the
death cure wrestling with a syringe with
a bendy needle
and a sticky glove that just won't leave
her alone
luckily she was able to pull it together
and handle medical equipment like a pro
for the final cut
who do you think the funniest member of
the maze runner's cast is
did you fart tell us your vote in the
comments and don't forget to hit
like if any of these got you to smile
if you want more maze runner content
feel free to subscribe
what about your pre-production training
i didn't go through this
i'm like a bed i wanna fly away